in italia esiste ancora un 10 per cento
di persone sfigate che si estendono ad
avere delle opinioni propri oggi però la
risposta un'attività cerebrale
scomodamente eccessiva e superfluo ce
l'abbiamo noi ed è basta basta basta
basta basta basta basta
vasco è oggi vogliamo presentare il
corso ai emo della collana di falda
autrice anche di corsi quali ai truzzo
ai nerd e hayden che potete trovare in
qualsiasi edicola al modico prezzo in
poco tempo e senza sforzo è riuscito a
diventare nei personaggi vincenti ha
anzi da tutti ma basta parlare andiamo a
vedere un pochino come funziona corrado
è un ragazzo che ha deciso di farci da
cani in questo video potete ben vedere
la prima cosa che salta all'occhio è il
vestito di merda che sta portando
addosso
ecco così va meglio la cintura fa
fighetto la maglietta ci fa credere che
sia uno tosto e pantaloni neri anche se
te fanno sudare nelle chiappe e di chi
ami te stai zitto o le scarpe da jackson
chiudi un occhio alle 10 ci ringrazierà
iv usate di in chiaro ma che serve cioè
tutta questa roba la stanza non per
cattiveria un po di caldo con queste qui
che so se l'ibrido pezzenti disoccupato
del cavolo vuoi guadagnare i 50 euro per
età da mangiare a tuo nipote
preferissero il solito morì la land
rover marciapiede ecco così va meglio a
questo punto aggiungendo un pochino di
oggetti quella da vidic azioni e coppa
vitto ai e mo mi hanno velocemente sulla
faccia ogni ragazzo emo che si rispetti
non può far mio tocco di trucco sugli
occhi euro franzoni era compagna ha
ammesso adesso dopo aver dato un look of
cool e in questo ragazzone un pochino
vedere l'atteggiamento che dovrebbe
tenere in pubblico rilievo sono emotivi
io ho pianto quando ho visto munero
sinceramente ma ha fatto piangere come
come film un po come come bambine ma ha
fatto piangere drive che fa fatto
piangere
la pubblicità di vito mi rompa quella
del mattino su tre rischia di non sono
depressi tutti i giorni trovano
deprimente qualsiasi cosa cioè io non
interessa nessuno c'è nessuno
non c'è verso una linea messo del mio
amico solo gli altri anni gli anni come
me che sono il pcm vogliono amico ma se
poi non sono abbiamo non mi vogliono più
come amico cioè le nostre un'amicizia
profonda quella ma la nostra idea o sono
vizi italiani ma che non ha fatto scacco
l'atto viene fatto mangiando mi il
cavallo con la torre cioè io sono così
piccineria mini scavando non lo mangio
vanko scacchi è cioè nel senso io penso
sulle regole ovvio che non me lo devi
mangiare quel cavallo perché sei tu si
mangia di cavalli anche del solo di
legno tono che deve lo spiega io queste
cose ma ragazzi
a che serve una personalità unica e
particolare se a nessuno interessa lato
meglio massificare si rimanendo al
vostro modo sempre uniti e unici quanto
la pecora in un ovile senso io voglio
dire che grazie alla collana e b bis art
la sanzione capito che se compro ultimo
modello e quindi se sono il primo set si
sarà famoso prima mi preoccupavo ad
andare bene a scuola a rispetto ai miei
genitori ad avere ancora dei valori
fondamentali per aida come la famiglia
l'amicizia l'amore
adesso ha capito sa che il mondo
volessero vinto una cosa bene e mi
chiedo cosa se la fabbrica dopo grazie
importante che ciò amici su myspace su
facebook a quella e l'amicizia scusa a
ecco è quella la vera amicizia quella
che dite io che ne so nel senso anche su
perso per sel mente l'uso dell'udito
perché vado in discoteca agli disco
house nella rosa del mai venuta cioè una
cosa che ti spegne andava avanti è una
cosa che viva musica a un personaggio
così paola questa musica soft air maroc
sembra davanti internet movimento su
abusi si fa coraggio
cosa aspettate a diventare come loro
coraggio ragazzi allora guarda colpe ne
funziona pure l'importante è che stai
attentissimo a seguire le stesse la
stessa procedura che si faceva con il
vaso mi raccomando se devo essere
sincero alla fine la pausa l'ho fatto un
pochino più lunga dei cinque minuti ho
chiamato un gruppo di cinesi per farmi
un massaggio di 20 ore perché stavo
veramente scappando lasciatelo dire cioè
il tuo commento ha vinto l'ho letto mi
sono detto basta questo qui va subito
come commento vincitore oddio mi ha
fatto morire e questo quello amo su un
truzzo orribile comunque siamo seri